my name's a Hanukkah cuckoo I'm gonna be
talking about building a canary testing
framework today for your distributed
systems so reintroducing myself
cuckoo I'm a senior engineer at github
or Twitter handles at koochoo and you
can [ __ ] that's my getting up handle
right there if you're interested into
that let's jump into this talk so first
things first a lot of people are
probably wondering what is a canary and
back when if i first learned about this
i was just like is this talking about
like a canary deploy something else and
it's actually referring to a canary in a
coal mine right so back in the day
people are miners he sees Canaries to
detect carbon monoxide poisoning
similarly in systems the canary is
something that runs continuously and
testing and alerting to problems in your
systems before your users notice them
there's other names for this like light
step which is a distributed tracing as a
service product has a good blog post
about mystery shopper monitoring and
it's the same concept as a canary so
highly suggest reading that and like I
mentioned earlier since it's like
detecting bugs and user-facing features
they should mimic user behavior and test
a very specific feature or functionality
of a system that is deployed for and
since we want to catch bugs in
production before they the users notice
them they should normally run against
your production system right
there's exception to this role but like
generally speaking it is good to run
them in production continuously and
honestly does it like my personal
opinion but I do feel that with the
canary in itself each product should
have its own canary this shouldn't be
all just mashed into one big model at
the canary because that way you can do
more fine grained tuning and alerting on
each of the Canaries and the tests that
pass and fail and whenever you go to
visualize them and the test execution
status they're not all going to be
jumbled together so yeah and you're just
like wait it's an integration test but
like yes and no not really right because
if you have this as an integration test
and we gotta hit that upgrade button you
kind of get like Canaries which are
integration tests on steroids
so like I'm really proud of myself for
this one actually I thought about this
like on Wednesday night I'm just like oh
I'm adding this
[Laughter]
basically what you get is like what
integration test I feel like they're
often stopped I'd like to database level
right like sometimes it works out well
like you have a lot of end-to-end
testing frameworks and like rails Django
even in the front end but in a
distributed system context the database
may not be the stopping point right
actually like in some context like the
way I learned about it the stopping
point wasn't the DB it was actually a
hypervisor so this is why we need to
build our own custom canary and it's
because we want to do more than just
simple crud operations right like
sometimes it's just doing oh hey create
this resource and ensure that was
created and persisted in a database
that's not necessarily enough so context
is I have my previous employer
digitalocean
I was working on networking products
right so our canary would be able to
build up or create droplets sure I'll be
persistent in a database but then we're
able to do more with it you can SSH into
the droplets you can run unix commands
such as like pink or even provisioning
it with like nginx and I worked on like
firewalls and our virtual private cloud
project and we're able to like test and
networking traffic between droplets with
multiple users and a single early user
and an integration test wouldn't have
been able to do that for us so that's
what we have that framework and other
teams had like interesting use cases for
Canaries as well like block storage with
provision a droplet and a volume and
then SSH into the droplet and run some
commands to see if ills mounted properly
right and you don't get this from most
of the integration testing frameworks
that are out there right now an
additional e write integration test the
context isn't necessarily as distributed
like at digitalocean we had something
like 13 data centers I believe I may be
off but um basically these canary tests
can be isolated to run in every single
region and we can also use various Linux
images that we have for all of our
systems and that way if one we like one
region is failing and the other ones are
healthy then something's weren't wrong
with the system deployed to that region
so that's pretty important and also you
get to like you can get some very
interesting race conditions caught like
on firewalls the canary I wrote
caught that there was a race condition
for whenever you create a droplet and
then you apply a firewall to it
immediately afterwards and then you get
locked out the droplet so yeah I don't
think an integration test well caught
that because even a test that we wrote
didn't catch that
outside of canary test and since the
canary is like just another service
that's deployed you can kind of get more
observability into what's going on into
your systems with also having like
structured logging and also like metrics
into the determine area framework itself
it helps to extend those and
additionally if you're using something
like tracing open tracing you can get
like see how that propagates from the
canary down to the hypervisor or
whatever your services are doing so
that's really nice as well so you're
probably wondering well how do I even
build this canary testing framework
right like we whenever we build anything
you kind of have to like lay out the
requirements right so for the context of
this talk we got like lay out some
necessary features first I want to see
the visual or we want to see the test
output and its execution status is it
did it pass did it fail like what's
going on and if it failed why did it
fail and we can save this into a
database which also mentioned later
recording and alerting on metrics via
Prometheus pretty much I think it'll be
nice to see how many tests have failed
how many are currently running and how
many have finished running and how many
have even been started also like we
don't want to run these tests like
synchronously you're like sequentially
right we want to be able to run them all
simultaneously like or concurrently
rather and we want to run them
repeatedly so maybe every ten minutes or
half an hour and maybe set a timeout of
10 minutes 20 minutes whatever on them
and these tests should be able to be
written in and something that's flexible
and approachable so not maybe not
necessarily something statically typed
right and so we have these requirements
so let's break you down into the actual
architecture component for the
underlying framework itself we're going
to write this would go
mainly because this is just a pretty fun
language and where I learned how to like
the canary firmer Kai help me in pain
was written and go so I have a lot
context around that for the test VM
itself we're going to use JavaScript and
it's gonna be embedded inside to go
framework itself and of course they're
gonna need a database for storing test
execution results and an API and a web
UI for visualizing the test execution
results that are stored in our database
and no I love your part I like why go
for the actual framework why not in
JavaScript if you write in JavaScript
test why not rust go doesn't have
generics but you know we get some good
genetic wins from using go write so
ghost concurrency model really helps us
out here because like we said we needed
to have simultaneous test execution with
using go routines we can run each test
in isolation isolated fashion in a its
own goroutine and that's pretty dope
right and also it goes context api were
able to set timeouts and it can
automatically cancel if that time i was
exceeded and there's decent support for
embedding languages like if we weren't
embedding javascript you know there's
the PM's for closure and there's a VM
for Lua and at digitalocean we used go
to' which is just a go did roshan api
client and if we wanted to rather than
making raw HTTP calls we could actually
embed that inside the VM itself and call
it from the JavaScript but we're not
using that in our example it's like why
javascript for the scripting language
why not writing it and go itself I
didn't go is larlie
I think goes kind of a little bit too
strict for these nitty gritty or like or
these quickly written tests that we want
to do to verify behavior so javascript
gives us a lot of flexibility and also
just made it faster to be more
productive to like build these tests
right and some may argue on this but low
barrier to entry like does law prior art
for like JavaScript itself and I know
some people have beef with it but
honestly right into test with JavaScript
was really quite nice to use with this
um framework and
we can't bet it with Ingo using auto
which is pretty clutch right and a
requirement that we needed so here are
these core components into an
architecture diagram pardon like tiny
text basically starting from the left we
have the canary daemon which runs
indefinitely
this will also serve as an API and also
serve up the web UI this will call will
configure the VM or the canary with what
it needs and call the test runner for
each test and that test runner will then
make a JavaScript VM for each test and
execute it and return those results back
to whether it's passed or failed with an
error all the way back to a daemon which
none can save it in the database and we
can use that to look it up in the web UI
and so if we break this down if I have
any overwatch fans here you'll know what
I'm referencing oh it said in my bio my
huge overwatch fan so had to do it to
him let's break it down a little bit
further right so at its core every
single test is instantiated and ran
inside of a JavaScript VM not a surprise
it allows us to write and run these test
scripts using javascript if we want to
add more features on to this framework
or like to the VM itself such as logging
or even like HTTP support because we're
not running like a v8 like embedded
inside of it right we can attach this to
the framework itself and we're able to
do this using auto which is by Robert
crimine and the JavaScript interpreter
written and go so next is up up it's a
test runner right
this also is responsible for isolating
the VM and it configures the VM with
necessary extensions and then just runs
a test inside of the VM itself and
returns errors if any from that test
execution the canary daemon is is what
calls a test Runner and is this going to
be running indefinitely and if it
executes a config file and then
registers the tests to run and I'm proud
to repeat myself but you repeatedly run
each test
and save the results today database and
also records and exports metrics such as
the test started the ones are running
and finished and we use Prometheus for
that and like we saw earlier also can
serve up an API and a front-end so it's
a lot take in
so let's actually look through some code
and like this framework itself and you
know we're talking about canary it's got
a nice little Birdman hand rub right
here so let's get into this code and in
the words of the young jeezy let's get
it yeah so let's talk about loading
these test configurations first and
foremost here's a function in a compact
package that we're using to load a
configuration file for each canary as
you can see it takes in an auto VM as
input which is just like JavaScript BM
and then it takes in an IO reader which
is just a file what happens next
or as an open configuration file then
we're also instantiating or defining
some functions that we can call from
within this JavaScript VM because you
see config BM set and let's see here
we're going to walk through these auto
functions a little bit but this context
object is actually really important
because it's the first thing that
happens after we copy our VM the shape
of it is that it has not only the config
a conflate object that takes in a name
it's an array of tests configs that are
going to be our tests that we actually
run right and these tests configs have a
name for them they all have a frequency
that they should be run at and they also
have a timeout for our like one day
should stop executing and also they take
an auto script which is a parson
JavaScript file used within them so now
that we have that out of the way let's
actually take a look at these two helper
functions that were defining here
they're called file and register tests
and these are basically helper functions
that we can use inside our JavaScript
itself so Auto func file is actually
setting a function definition on the VM
itself they'll take in one argument
which is it's going to be a file name
and then using go underneath the hood we
can actually open the file and parse it
into a string and then
turn it back in JavaScript and this will
get caught in conjuction with registered
test and we can look at that one next
well register tests the shape of this
function it's kind of different the
first argument is actually going to be
an object the second one is going to be
a source which is just a string of the
JavaScript actually executes for that
test right and something to notice is
that well actually I'll get back to that
let's go to this conflict out load
because it's actually important so these
are actually two very interesting lines
here basically this conflict that load
up function is taking the input and then
what we're doing is mapping over that
JavaScript object and it's keys and
basically you define what keys you want
from it and you're extracting that value
of that key into the go config object
underneath the hood and we passed a
pointer or you can see like on the first
line I need to comment that we have a
reference to a test config instance
right so it's just mutating that
instance of the object underneath in the
go program and then going back to this
we can see below the call to source we
can we're just instantiating that into a
test config object with the name into
frequency in the timeout and we're
compiling the source script into an auto
script and saving it into that instance
of that test config object and then
we're just appending it to the list of
tests and under the hood so now we're
back to this config like load function
right we have that all set up like
douses to helper functions underneath
the hood basically from that we're going
to call a reader on the file that's
passed in we're just going to take that
source config object and then that's
going to actually run the script inside
the config VM and with all those helper
functions defined will then be able to
return the context configuration or the
config object and also its array of
tests I've been created so if you look
at an example conflict IGS file here
right we have a frequency to find of 10
minutes
timeout to find 10 minutes register test
is that function that we defined in that
helper
in the helper function and it takes in
the name which is a simple example test
our frequency in time out and those are
on the object and then you see that file
function that we defined into VM as well
which opens up a simple example JS file
which is just a test script in this case
and this is all get stored in the
underlying go execution environment
which is a pretty dope
and just like you know that's cool but
how this even gets called we're gonna
create our daemon file and like call
this function so like let's say we just
had like this empty main file also I
left out package names like imports
because like it's only so much line
height and slide so bear with me y'all
go format got you back anyways um so if
you look at this main file here what
we're doing is basically accentuating
some flags to use with a canary daemon
the config path the working directory
for our test and then essentially we
create an instance of the auto VM and
we're just loaded calling must load
configs on this VM and with the config
pack itself muscle local configs
attempts to open that file name that we
pass in and then if it throws an error
maybe it doesn't exist is just going to
fatal and just gonna exit your program
right bar the net then we're calling our
canary load function and we got our
canary configuration and it's array of
tests that are running with it as well
then we need to return that back up to
the main function so like how do you
actually get running right well now we
can actually look at the test for logic
so we're in a different package again so
keep this in mind but the logic for
running the test is actually pretty lean
in comparison we basically start off by
making a copy of the VM so the test run
is actually running in isolation by
itself and this go routine that we're
starting is actually being used to
detect like if that context has a dead
line attached to it then basically if
there's anything like called or it times
out it will interrupt the VM and that VM
will return an error back to the back to
the run function
and then we can just call it like call
that test VN that we copied call run on
it and if it throws an error in the
underlying VM we can return that back to
whatever is calling our run function and
close that done Channel and yeah we're
cool with that
but right now the way exists if we don't
have any niceties in it right we just
have in es5 interpreter which doesn't
necessarily ship with like anything like
XML HTTP requests for like making HTTP
calls unstructured logging and like not
really anything useful right so let's
add some extensions and extend this VM a
little bit right whoops
so let's take a peek and add some
standard library functions into this VM
similarly to our convict load function
we can define a load standard live
function here right this is to have some
standard library functionality for usage
within the VM right now it takes a
context our VM and a package name which
probably standard or whatever you wanna
call it well and what is doing after
that is it's creating an empty
JavaScript object in that's an auto
value and then it's was doing with that
object is that it's converting it into
an underlying object and then what we're
doing after that is that we're making a
bunch of sub packages and looping
through them in order to create these
new or to attach these function at these
functions onto them and I'm just going
to go a deep dive into the OS package
first basically we make this OS package
struct and it has its load function
called onto it and then with that auto
util dot two package call that we have
here we have this get and function
defined on that OS package right and get
and as you can see in that get M
similarly to before like we did what
file basically we're able to extract a
key that's being passed in as input to
that function and what we're doing is
using to underlying go get in function
from the OS package to then return that
back to our JavaScript VM and it's
pretty dope and it's how it'd be called
from within a JavaScript like canary
test right this work turned that key of
whatever it's defined with the day
from it and this was useful in the
context cuz we used kubernetes for the
pointing that we had secrets or
environment variables to find there so
I'd be able to extract those secret from
there and it worked out pretty well
another thing that we need is like HTTP
support right so we wanna make some ret
Network requests the shape of this is
similar to to the load standard Lib it
takes into VM a package name an HTTP
client and a request configuration for
the HTTP client right then we can
instantiate an instance of this HTTP
package and load its helper function
into the VM and in this case we're going
to define do method on to this HTTP
package and I hate that I have this much
code on it because it's like microscopic
but basically the shape of this API is
that it's going before inputs to the do
function the first one's going to be a
method get post put options delete patch
second one will be a URL the third input
is going to be a header object and then
the fourth one is going to be a body and
then basically we're just going to make
in we're using the underlying HTTP
client attach that package and go to
make a client do request and that
returns back the responsible object and
we can return back to the JavaScript
status code the headers and a body and
this is how it looks like whenever you
call her from a canary script and by
default console dot log is unstructured
in JavaScript right these is no
structure to it at all and that's not
really good like you won't be able to
filter and query on things whether using
like elk timber blocks whatever people
use like for logging so we're going to
add a little bit of structured logging
to it and it's actually a wrapper around
log wrists which is a ghost structured
logging package and like similar to
before we're taking in a VM another
package name and a feel logger this
logger struct
field lager as one of its attributes and
basically has it's an interface that
exported by loggers and once again same
thing that we've seen before we're
adding support for four methods key
value KB is this basically allowing us
to attach key value pairs to our log
lines info logs with the level of info
of course error logs with level of like
error and then fail will actually log
with that level of error but then I'll
also throw an error so the canary test
stops running and I'm just going to take
a look at key like Cavey info and fail
so this is kind of a long method as well
I know I goofed
but basically has two shapes that this
API could take either you can pass it an
object to it and basically is this a
JSON object general key value or you can
have two strings or like a string and a
value just for a singular key value pair
as a function input and it's how info
looks like it's been doing before
basically what we're doing is that we're
able to call excuse me and get the
message from as a first input and we're
just calling the underlying logger using
our con underlying loggers info method
and we're just returning nothing because
I know up for a turn feyo does the same
thing otherwise we're calling an error
and then we're throwing an error in the
VM and here's an example about how we
can use this within our canary test with
one of the first API or one the singular
key value pair API so let's add them to
the VM and runner right basically below
our test VM that copy if we have all
this good stuff passed in like
essentially what we can just do is call
all of these functions with the context
and the test VM for a standard library
were just gonna give it like the package
name like standard or abbreviated HTTP
I'm just gonna call HTTP and log of
course gonna be log and yeah
it's pretty dope and now we can add to
run it to the daemon I've got to go fast
see
so in here what's really changed about
this is after we load our configuration
from earlier we can actually call launch
test method right let's see this will
take in the VM and canary config and
then an array of tests and also
afterwards we have a select block
meaning that'll block indefinitely and
never return and that's what makes it
Damon so now that we have launch test we
can actually call these this go run
tests forever or my Bible you can call
run tests forever in a go routine and
we're going to dig deeper into that so
here we can see that in this run test
forever what we're doing is we're making
a unique ID for every single test and
then we're able to create a new context
for each test that runs and like I was
talking about before like with the VM we
haven't that duration or that timeout
from every single test loaded into a
test configuration right so for every
single Tet a test configuration that we
have we can make a new context which
with and call whit timeout which sets a
deadline so if it runs any longer than
like 10 minutes if that's our like
timeout right the test will fail and
it'll say throw an error saying deadline
exceeded and then we can just call our
run underlying runner that run function
which will then we'll execute the canary
test and yeah if it goes an error we can
lock the air out and dead at the end
very end we're calling the time that
sleep because we want run it every 20
minutes we're just gonna sleep for 20
minutes until the next execution time
and so we have all these tests running
now right and now we want to actually
save our results to a database I really
like I finished building this framework
on Sunday so so I didn't wanna deal with
a sequel migration side to C's boat was
just a key-value database for go this is
how the interface looks like for the
canary test essentially we want a way to
start test and test
and get a singular test and also list
all the tests that we have in our
database and this is the shape of the
test instant models that we're using
within the database storage basically
things that we've seen already
you know ID name when did it start
one day and did it pass if it did in why
not
so fail cause satisfy its that and
basically we're going to implement this
interface using a bolt store it wraps
the underlying boat DB and then it also
adds an ongoing map which is just tests
are currently running in a mutex for
thread safety and a cancel func for just
other timeouts and so forth start test
we're actually not writing a to did
anything to the database yeah it gets
stored in that underlying ongoing map
and it's des stored with the in that map
with its ID as key and then when we call
n tests we can go into that map extract
that test instance from it and then
delete it from that map and then also
insert it into our boat database or data
store and basically is insert test is
just what is saving this test and cents
into the actual database and we can add
this to the JSON we'll add a flag for a
DB path to our configuration we'll also
make a new call for instantiating a
database and passing it down to both
launch tests and run tests forever and
basically most of them BOS is simply
like make a new instance of our boat
store and we're turning it back to us
and I know there's a microscopic but you
can see before or after we define the
context you can see that we're calling
start test and then after the runner
returns so we can just call end test and
pass in like the tests that we
originally created and yeah then it's
done and if we have our tests running
continuously now like we need a way of
visual visualizing the results from like
the database honestly I was gonna build
a react front-end for this but your boy
ran out of time so I decided to go with
the like graph QL so we're going to use
graph QL for our API cuz like you know
all the cool kids are using it nowadays
and we're gonna use G Co gen which is
kind of one and one the newer go graph
to old libraries and essentially we can
make a graphical application using G Co
gen to serve up everything and
essentially it makes two handlers a
query handler for the actual ape for
like the actual queries and then just
one for the graphical playground our
graph QL schema is a one-to-one mapping
to our database model and you can see
our queries are like test
singular test and then tests are
currently ongoing and then we have our
resolver methods for everything here so
basically this is calling doubt
underlying both stores
methods that we saw into interface to
list all the tests or get a single test
or get the ongoing test not too bad back
to the daymond
we're going to make a new function
called launch h HTTP after we
instantiate our database and this must
listen function just really creates a
listener TCP listener and that just
joins the host import together oh yeah
we have a listen host on this important
at the beginning daring new flags launch
HTTP creates a new instance of that
graph QL application for our front-end
and then it just launches it in a go
routine so it doesn't block the main
thread and it just will run in the
background and since our daemon runs
indefinitely that HTTP server will stay
up and since I didn't have time build an
actual front-end we can actually use
like the graph QL playground and what
kind of contrast and then you can see
the test execution their zones and then
last but not least we got metrics so
good old Prometheus and there's going to
be a quick one essentially I started off
by making we can start by making a
metrics package I have a really grimy
abstraction around like
Prometheus register and we can register
other metrics like to go process
collector and just like memory and all
that good usage and it also returns a
handler for our metrics itself or
themselves and so inside of our canary
daemon will instantiate this node right
and we'll pass the handler into the
launch of HTTP function and a metric
Snowdown tarde test Runner and launch
HTTP we're just actually going to use on
this new handler to be mounted at the
metrics sub path on our HP server and
they're going to be exported for
scraping using like prom alert and
didn't a run test forever function we
can define a few like let's see two
counters for started and finished and
then a gauge for running since it will
fluctuate up and down and also note that
we'll have a result label attached to
our finished counter so then for our
text execution right this changes up a
little bit whenever we start a test we
can call it a started counter and add
one for running we'll also add one but
then we'll add a defer which is then
like well with the negative one so flux
weights up and down then after it
finishes running we can say okay if it
finished it had an error it's going to
be a fail right so we can like add one
to our finish counter and give it a
label a fail for the result but if it
didn't it's gonna be a pass so we can
add that label instead and then if you
go to the metrics path on like in the
browser you can see those are Prometheus
metrics and you can see various things
out running into test names and all that
good stuff and we're done I'm gonna see
if I can demo this right quick let's
hope this works out because you know how
that goes so here it's like how do I
exhibit in I'm playing
oh wow II know it's quit um so let's
open up a canary test I'm going to open
up simple HTP ejs and basically we're
just gonna use our HTTP method that we
defined earlier and it has a do method
we're gonna use a get we're gonna call I
Can Has IP calm because I didn't know
what else to call and we're going to
return or log out what the test output
is or the output of the response in a
cave in a key value pair oh yeah
so yeah that good Thanks a problem oh
okay this one so now if we like restart
it I'm gonna start my canary daemon and
if you look at the very last line right
we can see we can see like okay we get
our the body returned and basically
return just IP address and a structured
logging so you can see the key of body
that we used and what it output it as
well output as well into name the test
and it's ID and to log message as a
first value and then also if I go to my
browser here here we go and we query you
see we have a test called always fail we
can get logs back from that or to fail
calls from that always fail always I can
as IP oh I went through an error no such
host and then you get simple example
tests nothing it passes and just for it
impress posterity i'ma so always fail
here basically always fail will always
just call logged I fail I'll always err
out you know obviously let me see let me
get back my slides okey no crashed cool
dude
extend this time
all right yeah uh I put the code up on
here at simple canary I haven't written
to read me so yeah it does no test hey
it worked
so yeah I'll get to that eventually but
yeah check it out wait hold up hold up
Thank You y'all two condo I want to take
Antoine Grondin back where ever I worked
at digitalocean really good friend of
mine mentor friend or whatever you call
them he originally created like the
canary framework at the draw ocean and I
actually just got tired of bugging him
all the time so I started helping him
maintain it but he kind of taught me how
Canaries work and their functionality
and yeah he also gave me like to go
ahead to give this talk and like pass
his knowledge on to y'all as a proxy in
a way so yeah
he's awesome and I want to thank him
even though he's not here and questions
I'm going to switch to slide oh well
this light is up y'all mind unless it's
somebody from the crowd it has a
question what's up
you'd be surprised so I think it depends
right cuz like whenever I worked at
digitalocean like I was working on
networking products and like this
framework for an example use case it's
like we could we get spin up one droplet
here SSH into it spin up a separate
droplet SSH into it apply a firewall
policy that lets like I don't know TCP
traffic over port 80 through and then on
that first and then on that same droplet
it has that policy we can install nginx
which automatically has like its default
page serving to up on like that IP
address and port 80 then in that second
droplet we can then SH into a an exec a
command to like a curl command to curl
that IP of the other droplet and verify
that the pages return back but I think
like and but there was a lot of things
that we had to verify and even with
virtual private clouds we had to users
like with separate API tokens but we
want them to spin up a droplet with
private networking and another one with
private networking and then verifying
that their network traffic can't talk to
one another it's like kind of like it
seems like overkill but honestly it's
like a like since it's all security
based products like we don't like we
didn't want people to be like oh my god
why can they like spy traffic or
something like that you know so I guess
it's like all depends right like y'all
depends on what like your problem space
is and what you're working on but it's
like we were talking about integration
testing is like well we can't use the
API who wants to actually write bash
scripts to do and and testing
verification that's not like scalable
and just give us way more flexibility so
it's it depends like I know that's a
very broad answer but yeah see I think
someone else had a question
I'd say so I think it says I mean it
sounds about right yeah I mean you
trying to verify that user behavior is
like as expected I always personally
always thought about accepting tests up
being like something which imma call it
what's what I'm looking for like UI
driven but our of our canary tests are
like API driven because um at least the
ones that in the context of do and that
just was for like I don't know problem
spaced reasons and we but yeah they are
form of fix our acceptance testing as
well some biocide a question oh yeah
what's up yeah
yep so a few could repeat that yeah
[Music]
yeah oh I'd argue you would I don't know
because it's like a canary is mimicking
a user itself right like in the use case
I had like we didn't have to necessarily
increment like a specific we don't have
any like global state like that although
like they're pretty isolated context but
also the canary does help seeing like
for each service like if something does
go wrong in another service like it goes
down it can propagate back up to UI or
like to decayed bury itself so it all
depends and I had one question on slide
oh it's talking about canary releases
and deployments proxying routing
percentages of traffic nothing else for
canary well it's not canary releases
before canary we just literally deployed
it to our kubernetes cluster with the
scale of one because it's like just a
single context and no percentages we
will just like hit production and hope
for the best and I think I got time for
one more question if anybody has one
subdued
like anything I think there was
something on the server side like we we
had like user IDs for like we had canary
geezer so we get those out for me like
analytics that's necessary but also it
depends because I share like a case
where we had like analytics at the API
level or at least a public API level but
I do know that the UI had went to a
different API like an HTTP or JSON API
that a canary
Dallas aha all right
[Applause]